me and Gary Vee up in that Hall what's
cooking I'm aware what are you doing
here so good for you the sooner the
better would [ __ ] like that I know and
you look good thanks that's for sure so
yeah it's it's a big career change you
can't make overnight so I was like one -
I'll take advantage of the time and
really like get some clarity and think
about other things a little bit cuz you
can't make big decisions like that we're
so gonna think of a be like I don't
perspective I can't see anything so
right so yeah I mean there's so like I
feel like there were so many factors
that kind of played a role of course but
I don't know the past couple of months
like all the cards kind of lined up
perfectly I was just like this is right
good for you so yeah thank you for
everything thank you I mean it's been an
awesome three years like I mean I told
like surely this and I'll tell Claude
this later like at the end of the day I
like really do I leave with a lot of
good vibes and I felt very and just like
loved and support it and you don't find
that a lot of agencies or a lot of
places in general so yeah it's not every
it's weird to leave is there anything I
can help with in this next chapter
anyway probably yeah don't be don't be
shy no I believe you I know what makes
you good about anything I think I need
to kind of figure out what I do so huge
can I give you can I give you a quick
piece of advice every world is like that
yeah don't let that [ __ ] you and go
narrow to what makes you pop
motivational speakers are my most hated
people yet I hate that up yet I get
categorized in that world all the time
right but I'm not crippled because I
know that I'm not trying to do the wrong
thing right the wrong thing this is
buying it forget about that
if you don't ever look for the white
space that doesn't exist yeah do what
the [ __ ] you know what you like if you
know yoga yoga's plenty [ __ ] katic
you know yeah being the cream rises to
the top business not in the I'm gonna
see something nobody else sees so so all
the people that are doing the wrong
thing crowded not authentic it just has
nothing to do with you yeah yeah I'm not
crippled by other agencies sucking up
giving a [ __ ] about people that's the
thing you need to do yeah it's a really
good piece of advice like what do you
want to do and do it and literally
eliminate a real
it's super [ __ ] simple so because we
get taught we get taught yeah we get
taught and I think in hindsight my
inability to learn that way became my
greatest strength yeah and I feel like
but once you learn that way it's very
hard it's very hard it the same way I
can't do the other thing
I can't run anything like that normal
way you know yeah well a lot of people
are like you know what you're doing it's
like you know it's kind of risky and I'm
like I don't know risky for just don't
believe in this whole notion of like
okay you graduate you can you can pick
up back from come work here I'm in the
same spot yeah I also just don't I
actually think it's the other ways risky
I me too because I think it's really
easy to become complacent and understand
I don't I don't know I don't think it's
deviating from a path because I don't
think there is a path there's way too
much respect for anybody who thinks what
you're doing is risky yeah I mean I've
literally gotten a response in like one
person but like my family is like yes
100%
like there's so and the person that's
you know saying that is you know
respects a certain narrative and that's
awesome too that's great for that and
maybe great for them forever
yeah maybe right but yeah I've always
been a pleasure to question yeah so I
knew that this was gonna happen at some
point if you matter of like mine I'm
happy to help when you get through the
process thank you yeah I will definitely
hit you have fun on that at some point
when I have kind of like some clarity
about life i when I'm back if I come
back who knows okay
what are you going um well I was gonna
do South America but I just changed now
I'm gonna do it Asia because I want to
spend some time in India and do like
Chinese like ancient like Ayurvedic
medicine and study study that and
probably spend some time in Indonesia -
and Nepal like farming it's cool
it just is a place that aligns more like
my personal interest
I love it yeah amazing which is what I'm
gonna put into in February just kind of
sort of haze ever see that so thank you
thank you for everything really
really I mean it ping me if you need me
[Music]